so do you anticipate being world
class in multiple games i think so yeah
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
we have a very special guest probably
the youngest
of our guest speakers today um we're
really excited that kyle
buga guys gearsdorf is here he's a 17
year old professional
fortnight streamer and player of the
sentinels esports organization
he has been crowned the fortnight world
champion
in 2019 by beating out 40 million
competitors
wow worldwide and he outscored the final
100 contestants in the finals i don't
know if you guys have ever seen kyle
play but
the dexterity and and and
the speed of which he works is just
phenomenal to watch
buga was also crowned both the pc rookie
player of the year
and the pc player of the year at the
esports awards last november
of 2019. kyle or should we call you
booga we are so excited that you were
here he is at
b-u-g-h-a on twitter welcome to the show
what's up guys thank you for having me
it's so good to see you
we met last year at the super bowl with
your parents
and you have the coolest setup out of
all of us i have to
and and very good taste and hoodie
material i'm very
i'm very thankful for that i appreciate
the shout out brother
what uh first of all it's great to see
you i hope you've been well it's always
great to
see you instead of just texting um
what's the biggest from your perspective
as
one of the great players in this space
going through it obviously having the
iconic moment that a lot of you like
you were the reason a lot of people took
note about esports or that tournament
you're winning and how big the prize
money was obviously that made enormous
news throughout the world like what do
you continue
to like laugh in your young man's head
when you hear people talking about
esports because you're in it and what
kind of makes you snicker
or laugh what's the biggest
misperception
you think from the the masses or the
parents or
the mainstream media or just like that
that cliche thing that always makes you
kind of snicker of like if they only
knew
yeah i mean it would probably be like
thinking that all gamers are just these
sit behind their desk
nerds they don't do anything else they
play the game 24 7
or unhealthy all that like that's just
honestly it's not true
at least for me but um it's probably the
biggest thing
and what about and what about how you
see you know
the space evolving what's the biggest
difference in the macro space and again
what's great about a show like this is
we have cmos and we have you know
obviously
after this a team owner but like from
just your perspective from your
eyes what's the biggest thing that's
shifting in the last six months or 12
months
about the space about even and by the
way even if you want to go into your
your own game play or things that nature
like what's kind of happening
yeah i mean recently esports has just
been like evolving and blowing up i've
seen
so many more businesses organizations
just everyone's just getting into
esports now
just it's growing widely um
but for me right now playing fortnite
there
hasn't been too much in the fortnite
scene just kind of like a new season
going on
but um you see a lot of popping in
what about you know this is probably
going to be fun
for people here like just your
perspective what about the younger crew
of players coming up right like what are
you even seeing from like the 12 13 14
year old set and you're like
whoa that kid like i think people you
know obviously you're paying attention
you're seeing different ways people
playing and i also know that you're
expanding and
trying out different games and things
that nature anything anything catching
your eye
as an innovation like anything from a
hardware
what kids are using or mindsets or
strategies or any kind of
nerdy deep like i know a lot of people
watching who are players or aspirational
players so you can give us a different
perspective here
yeah i mean all the time players that
are evolving everyone's getting better
at the game like all the younger players
right now are kind of coming up and
pushing some of the older guys out
because they're so much more mechanical
and they're like way better in fights
and everything
so some of them are kind of dominating
right now but
for me real quick real quick tell
everybody
how old you are and how old these young
guys are because you know
literally you just delivered i'm still
hanging in there and i think
a collective ten thousand people just
threw up because
like they're like what the hell is this
scandalous but like but paint the
picture
you as like an older guy or an og like
what age group are you talking about
some of the younger guys
and where did where do you sit in
comparison by age yeah i'm
17 and in the four nights scene right
now that's kind of like middle age
coming up to the like later ages and the
younger guys are like 13
14 they're all coming up but yeah i
don't know it's kind of shocking like
i'm 17 and i'm in the middle age group
kind of later age group in a game like
that's just so weird
kyle your perspective one last thing
before we get to rob and i really
appreciate you taking time because of
how busy you are
for jumping on and giving us some
firepower here
do you think in esports we don't think
about lebron
even though lebron james actually talks
about playing tight end in the nfl like
the magnitude of like the way
professional sports as we've known it
you haven't seen that crossover your
prediction
your own opinion of your own self and i
know you have great quiet confidence so
i'm just giving you the room to
speak to that the crossover ability
you know dion sanders bo jackson two of
the only ones who've ever really done it
do you as these games get established
and we really see
7 12 19 22 really capturing
the attention of the world do you
personally anticipate
certain kids coming along and being
great at three or four
do you think that's too hard your hot
take because i'm
genuinely curious about how that plays
out yeah so i mean like
i think a lot of it is just dependent
upon the person so like me for example
any game that i'm going to i'm always
trying to improve i'm always trying to
get really good at it
like that's just my competitive drive so
i don't know i think it would be easy
if you are that type of person but if
you're not maybe you're just good at one
game
but for me personally so do you
anticipate
being world class in multiple games
i think so yeah and and when you watch
other people and you're just watching
have you seen some people emer you think
do you think it is a psychological
competitiveness
oh 100 yeah and and you don't think it's
a
hand-eye kind of core like you don't you
think it's
certain genre games will map like this
fortnight map to being good at fifa
or is that completely impossible in your
mind of making that transition
versus another game that has a similar
format
yeah like if we're going to another like
third person shooter i think it could
translate really well
right but i think it would take more
time to get used to like a sports game
or something entirely different
so understood well kyle listen i i want
to get to rob because i think he's gonna
bring some great perspective
for the people on and i really
appreciate you making the time and kind
of surprise guesting here so thank you
thank you for having me guys hey
everybody on youtube first of all thank
you so much so humbled for your time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out